انا الان حول هذا الموضوع من اسطنبول
الكاتب والباحثه السياسي طه عوده
اوغلوسيطها اهلا بك على قناه
كما شاهدنا في التقرير القوى الكبرى همم
تبدو غير راضيه بشان تحركات انقره ونيتها
التوغل البريا في شمال سوريا روسيا كما
راينا عززت وجودها في شمال سوريا هل سيغير
ذلك من حسابات انقره
ان تبدا قبل ايام ولكن
توقعات الدوليه ما زالت هي همم
روسيا لهذه العمليه هناك الروس على الرغم
الحاج الماسه لتركيا في هذا الوقت بسبب
الروسيه الالكترونيه لكن لاحظنا ان نوقف
الروسي هو متفق نوعا ما همم مع الموقف
الامريكي ضد التدخل التركي او التمر
التركي في الشباب
التي اشترت ما بين مسؤولين عسكريين
امريكيين وهو اتراك ساعات الاخيره الماضيه
التي تم يعني اكتشاف منها بانها هناك تحت
امريكيه ترفض التغيير الخريطه على الساحه
همم السوريه وهذا حقيقه ما يزعج الجنب
التركي وما نراه يوميا هناك تصريحات
مستمره متكرره ولكن همم اقوى من ما كانت
عليك في اسبانيا اقصد من قبل المسؤولين
اتراك بنيتهم بالتوكل بالشمال السوري حتى
انهم تم تحديد الاماكن التي سوف يتم سن
العمليه البريه كادل رفعت منبج وعين العرب
لكن هل هناك خطر ان همم يكون هناك تماس
ربما بين قوات تركيا اذا توغلت في الشمال
السوري مع قوات روسيه او اخرى
يعني حاله اخواته التركيه عندما تقوم باي
عمليه بريه واسعه يكون هناك تنسيق او
اختار اذا حتى هذه اللحظه نستطيع ان نقول
لا يوجد هناك تفاهم على التنسيق ولكن ان
تقوم انقره بالاختار وهذا ما تحاول انقر
ابلاغ في الجانب الامريكي وحتى الروسي بعد
الاصطدام ولكن تبقى هناك عوائق من قبل
واشنطن وهي خاصه متعلقه بمستقبل قصده التي
هي همم انتقلت اتحد الامريكيه خلال ايام
الاخيره خوفا من ان تتخلى عنها لصالح
الحليف التركي واخصنا في هذا الوقت الذي
هي ايضا بحاجه الى انقره في ظل الوضع في
اوكرانيا
حاول يعني همم ان تناول قدر المستطاع ان
تشيل هذه العمليه حتى لو كانت همم محدوده
ليس الخلافه الجوهري ربما ما بين تركيا من
جهه وروسيا والولايات المتحده من جهه اخرى
ليس الخلاف الجوهري هو في اعتبار الاكراد
فعلا خطرا لتركيا وايضا منظمه ارهابيه كما
تراها انقره
مختلفه ما بين الاطراف وخاصه الاطراف
الامريكي واطراف الروسيه
لمحاربه تنظيم داعش لكن في مقابل ترى
بانها يتمثل خطرا على القوميه له قدام
القضاء على تنظيم داعش في عام 2009 10
نسائيه تحاول قدر الامكان اقناع الجانب
الامريكي بضروره يعني الايفاء بشروطها
وخاصه التي ابرمتها في عام 2019 ونتعلقه
بابعاد الوحدات الكويديه عن حدودها وصحب
السلع من قوات خاصه
من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
التوضيحات